what advice would you give to an already
established Channel like with one two
three four million subscribers how to
like 10x it like increase it
um without losing major yeah that's
where it's very specific like Channel by
Channel you can't give general advice
okay yeah because if I do millions of
creators are gonna see this and they're
gonna do it and I'm gonna [ __ ] them over
you know oh I see so let's say I had
like two million subscribers on this
podcast yeah like how would you 10x that
without sacrificing what it is 10x is
your stuff does it matter so we you've
talked about with success yeah it's
different for everyone like is 10xing
your definition of success no well then
it's gonna right off the bat it's hard
because if you don't give a [ __ ] about
10x thing it's even harder than 10x
um he does this because he likes helping
people that's one thing I found
throughout this day every time I talk
data it's so funny with him because it's
like you know you could do this to get
more views and he'll just be like blank
I'll be like that doesn't register
anything he just like doesn't care which
is it's really I'm really nervous about
that I'm really nervous about the
numbers of affecting because it's so fun
oh yeah it's so fun to focus on the
numbers and I'm I'm really worried about
that but at the same time you should be
cognizant of that because you've created
not just some of the most watched videos
but some of the most amazing videos ever
so it's there's a strong correlation
there it's not like you're selling your
soul to make a highly viewed video it's
actually if you look at the metrics it
helps you understand what is compelling
and not and so I feel like I am
uh
I feel like there's some value to
investigate what work when people tune
on and when not to be more data driven
even on podcasts but I'm really afraid
on the flip side I think part of the
appeal is that you don't care about that
kind of stuff
but there there could be stuff that
doesn't have to do anything with that it
has to do with stylistic choices of
lighting and cameras or maybe with uh
um for example topics yeah you know like
even what you've asked me here is like
different than what most people ask me
yeah so it could be I mean and it'd be
nice to understand that but yeah again
I'm worried about polluting at the end
of the day it's it's this is a true case
of it's your own intuition like you know
your viewers better than anyone else
it's whatever see I'd like to push back
on that I really don't you do I do well
name one person who knows your viewers
better than you
uh somebody that looks at numbers of
podcasts no you know your viewers you
know you're the only how many episodes
Have You Done uh 350. exactly but I'm
not paying it you're the only one who's
watched every second of all 350 of them
probably that's just that's just not no
I haven't but the okay well because you
did it so you do know what's in all of
them sure your content is you people I'm
telling you you do and this is just one
of those moments where you're an
intelligent guy and you just have to
trust your like instincts like just
think what is the typical Lex viewer and
what do they want I don't think like
that my tip but that's all you would
have to do and whatever your gut tells
you that would be the best guess you
don't know what the typical viewer is
though I don't I know because to
investigate that would be very very
difficult and then you have to start
looking at the numbers you have to start
to like consider demographics the only
way I know that anybody even watches it
is because I'll sometimes run into
people like when I run along the river
and they'd be like I love you Lex it's
like okay well that that's that's the
data point and they're like cool people
but you know I don't know any like I
don't have any other
it's difficult man it's difficult to
know
it's difficult to know who listens to
boxes the difficult and do you have a
sense of who's I mean like you're so
huge that everybody watches yeah uh but
no I still do I would say if you were to
just put a gun to my head and you're
you're like all right we're gonna pick a
random person that watched your last
video and you have to like roughly guess
what they are and if you're not close
we'll kill you I would say probably like
a teenager that plays video games like
some some like that would be probably
the typical one and then there are
people that are maybe a little bit
younger a lot of people are older as
well but in a ramble random sample size
yeah it's probably like I'm a male boy
that plays video games like that's the
best way I would describe it but I don't
try to pertain to them I just make
whatever I think is interesting and good
content
um and this is what we were talking
about before even though hypothetically
35 to 40 of my audience is uh women
which is you know less than a majority
if we get 100 million views of video
that's still 30 to 40 million females
that watch every video which is probably
the largest uh you know views per video
for women on the whole platform which
you wouldn't think that you know uh like
I can't think of a single other creator
that gets more women to watch their
videos than that
um and so it's just anything even like
people above the age of 30 even if it's
only like three or four percent that's
still three to four percent of 100
million views there's a lot of people
that age so we we hit a large group of
uh of kind of every demographic if that
makes any sense so what if we look at
other maybe more challenging kinds of
channels or not but if we look at
educational for example like lectures or
if we look yeah educational it could be
short videos like how would you
10x that like uh something on Robotics
and biology on science on engineering on
all of that that's more educational
focused we would honestly just have to
pull the because it's the same way if
you went to Gordon Ramsay you said how
would a new cook cook better you know
it's like even then that's not even
specifically you have to go Channel by
Channel you really do or I'm I'm given
horrible advice because if there was
these just school rules everyone do it
you know what I mean like if there's
these magical little principles how
quickly when you look at a channel can
you kind of give advice yeah it's it's
like surface love at the start and then
the more if we watch 10 videos I feel
like I'd have a good profile and I could
tell you in my opinion you know
especially once I look at the analytics
and I get more ingrained in like okay
the typical viewers this they're from
here here's how they're feeling you know
because there are people who make videos
for rednecks and like the Rednecks Taste
of content is just so much different
than obviously women watching makeup
videos which are so much different than
you know teenage boys watching a
Minecraft video they're just all
different so the biggest thing you have
to do put your head your head in the
headspace of the viewer and see the
content how they would because if you
just try to only give your taste which
is what a lot of people do and things
from your perspective it's very biased
and it's just not going to work for
everyone and that's actually how you do
more harm than good which is something
I'm very careful of yeah but at the same
time just generating a lot of ideas I
think the first time I've talked to you
was on clubhouse actually yeah I
mentioned something about robots and
like almost immediately you went to
generating a bunch of ideas around oh
yeah uh it's just 100 Robots versus a
hundred humans yeah how far can a robot
throw a potato I think your idea like I
think the first idea was because you
just said so many ideas I never even
thought of
but it's it's it shows the value of uh
basically brainstorming with people that
think differently but at the end of the
day my ideas are probably you know might
lean towards some people a little bit
younger than your audience like some of
the stuff yeah but there's still the
ideas like I think the first one you
said because we're talking about uh
quadruped like a robot dogs you said to
replace a biological dog with a robot
dog and see if the owner notices
something you're just quickly
brainstorming different ideas of like
how this was years ago I remember yeah
which is just I mean it's like oh yeah I
never really thought about that kind of
so it's the basic the tension between
what does it take for a robot and our AI
system to replace the biological systems
that we the biological creatures that we
that we love in our lives yeah and but
like that was like the um
the pace of idea generation
was the thing that struck me today and
in general it's like that's how you get
at good videos is you keep keep things
it's much easier to make a video around
a good idea obviously than a bad one
you're just setting yourself up for
success